parents at a local charter school are
searching for answers after they say
students ate marijuana edibles on campus
and parents were not immediately
notified this happened friday at quest
preparatory academy near craig and
rancho in the northwest valley kate
houston is live in studio after speaking
to a mom who says there needs to be
better emergency protocols here kate yes
parents say a student brought the
edibles to school and gave them to
several other kids some knew what they
were eating others didn't the mother i
spoke to says the school did not
immediately contact parents and
paramedics were not called quest
preparatory academy serves students
kindergarten through eighth grade janae
simultan says her daughter was one of
the students that ate an edible but was
not told until after that it contained
marijuana simpleton says this happened
in the morning and parents didn't find
out until hours later at school pickup
simultan's daughter has asthma she
doesn't understand why the kids did not
receive medical attention as a parent we
can't help to think about the
possibilities of what could have
happened you had a kid fall asleep on
the table my daughter fell asleep on the
floor in her backpack
he had another kid walk out crying
another kid thrown up
those are all signs for me that
medical officials should have definitely
been contacted and they were not
simultan says she tried to speak to the
principal but says she was told the
principal was not available due to a
holiday party she says they did
communicate hours later but she wants
more to be done to ensure this doesn't
happen again simpleton plans to contact
the state public charter school
authority which oversees quest
preparatory academy
and i have reached out to quest
preparatory academy as well as the state
public charter school authority for some
more information on their safety
protocols when minors ingest drugs i
have not yet heard back sasha